vladimir poutine soutient une
proposition franco-allemande visant à
relancer au niveau européen les contacts
directs avec la russie et le chef d'état
russe a déclaré le porte parole du
kremlin dmitri peskov
elle a souligné que le président russe
estime que bruxelles et moscou ont
besoin d'un dialogue
je vous propose d'écouter notre
évaluation de cette initiative est
positive le président poutine est
partisan du rétablissement des
mécanismes de dialogue et de contacts
entre bruxelles et moscou le président
poutine l'a dit à maintes reprise
bruxelles et moscou ont effectivement
besoin de ce dialogue
bien évidemment nous suivons de près le
sommet qui a lieu aujourd'hui à
bruxelles et les évaluations de ce
dialogue éventuels qui seront faites là
bas pour le moment aucun préparatif
réelle n'a eu lieu
le fait est que cette initiative a
effectivement été proposé par angela
merkel ensuite soutenu par emmanuel
macron les la discussion au sein de
l'union européenne aura lieu avec la
participation d'autres états membres
c'est pourquoi il est très important de
voir s'ils sont d'accord sur ce point le
ministre russe des affaires étrangères
sergueï lavrov a quant à lui souligné
que le président russe avait des
contacts réguliers avec ses homologues
français et allemande pour ce qui est du
sommet union européenne-russie il y as
pour lavrov en lien chronologique avec
le sommet poutine byden à genève
écoutez nos au moins une chose est
claire juste l'autre jour l'union
européenne approuve une nouvelle
politique à l'égard de la fédération de
russie qui est formulée comme une
politique reposant sur trois principes
la riposte la dissuasion et
l'implication là où c'est intéressant
pour l'union
bn si cette philosophie est au coeur de
l'initiative du sommet il sera très
intéressant pour moi de voir comment un
tel événement hypothétique évoluera et
donc cela devrait immédiatement être
suivis d'une riposte
et puis ce sera la dissuasion cacao box
et comment tout cela va se combiner
c'est encore difficile à dire lors de
son discours devant le bundestag la
chancelière allemande angela merkel a
appelé l'union européenne à un dialogue
direct avec le président russe a pour
elle l'union européenne doit discuter du
format d'un éventuel sommet entre les
dirigeants européens et le président
russe